o ato suor de quem fala é o dado que
sejam muito bem vindos é mais um vídeo e
eu os trato já que satanás
atual campeã a questão da que os jogos
do épo turístico no méxico é medo irmão
como não tem seis jogos - do terror
assim do jeito que o curta jogar vamos
jogar os mais puros memória mesmo jogar
e ver o que tem de novo o o droga o que
importa o que é importante tanto tais
total russo que vê na moneytinho losing
track convites produção desliga seu
celular consulta e pelo irmão está a
bola só ao nível em oulu dem já começa
outra rua ou num eu sinto que denuncie
outra vez nós precisamos tentar ou eu
vou dar um ser outra vez havia uma
introdução para seguro já era onde é que
nós temos será que o turno matutino não
estou claramente numa sala do é linda do
e moderno olha só nós ps ontem que a
chave do nosso carro bem gostoso tem uma
caneca com que água café será não saibam
sair daqui o tema já uma porta entre
encostada no seu conteúdo sexual prepara
em si próprio roni está muito iluminado
para o meu gosto após correr o eu meu
deus olha só os gráficos bem gostoso já
refletiu no chão olha só a tecnologia
que é o que as postou o uruguai cima mas
não quer saber vamos vamos subir as
escadas ampla êxito governo sou muito
preguiçoso prepará-la bom então não
vamos próximo vamos tentar explorar a
que esta zona onde estão o valor nem a
quantidade é a hora
acho que inferno o que inferno anda lá
tá tudo escuro e agora possa atender a
porta na área ambiental que costuma ter
uma faixa vai com ok vamos lá então
explorar a não misturar [ __ ] nenhuma
chapa que já morreram acabou a farsa o
mx uma fênix mexidas cinza esfinge do
tomsk diferente isto numa caverna com
lâmpadas o que é melhor som surround
facto escola tem o finais notamos uma
prisão dentro de uma caverna com em
pedra concreto nem bem duro essa parede
bem dura olha essa textura bem gostosos
agora o que eu tenho que fazer tudo
dentro da prisão eu só tenho que me
inscrito em uma um saco de batatas está
supostamente minha cama mas não só como
contratar pessoal é assim que trato
titanic e tenistas é assim que eles
tratam a mas tem uma lâmpada ecológica
am 2.4 chega perto de conquistar o sul é
mais um de costa neto uma perguntar a
mim eu serei eu que vou falar comigo é o
personagem que está dentro do jogo que o
tua cara tá falar comigo derrotou a
garantir é que em senhor do preço no
breque guarda há sempre um guarda curto
que tem pulmão uma argola com boa chave
onde é quando os guardas guarda noturno
não editavam francês será que o poço por
isto a este jogo tem comandos é isso se
ganhar não é as portas abrem agora eu
percebo então vamos tentar abrir a que
esta porta a não pode ser tem nenhum
cadeado após a sentido é isso que o
jogador está muito escurinho nesta parte
vamos andar em frente também arrombaram
esta célula e agora o olho pintado no
canto olha olha aqui daqui vou sair do
ritual do satanás what's going on line
rir o que possui que o elenco com sangue
meu deus já começam as coisas por hora
mas joga aqui também come batata e já
comeu tudo olha só o pacote brasil
acabam cedo aqui era preciso apanhar
aqui alguma coisa assim eu acho que esta
pessoa era tipo guarda nem porque está
ela está lá com aquela calça azul mesmo
a guarda e botas da tropa eu acho que
era o governo a cavaco silva que está na
hora de ir embora ó qual é por edu meu
deus o demônio poço que o como um filho
foi bem rápido possível esta porta até
fechada tem o dia também ora bolas para
o levava já não posso entrar ali essa
também está farto de chatô alagoas
terrier olga como eu fui assistir a uns
80 não só resta portanto aí está a abrir
tantas em que agora é preciso pôr um
braço do rio porque a porta estava
enferrujada aí está muito escura que não
foi eu não quero mas não foi meu gol
mesmo ou mesmo nada aconteceu [ __ ]
vamos chegar aqui à porta da entrada
fechada também essa porta se o uso
pessoal veja uma lista tem sangue será
culpa sua que demore onde estão que o
apanhei não sei q [ __ ] que eu apanhei
mas apanhei eu acho que é uma bala de
uma pistola assim não saiu um de gera
vamos fugir solo é perigoso
o satanás satanás da partida outra vez
mas não só é um pentagrama olha no que
deu só para a china
e não olha o outro olha no que deu os
dois disputam uma porta aberta né não
está atrás pedra preciso ver o que é
isto mudou está sem textura eu esquecer
ou estudar uma textura no estudo eu tem
dentro em branco só o que pude escutar e
amarelo não percebemos como chinesa não
só isso algo vocês vêem que estão
pentagrama do satanás quando está em
caixa da fruta ao lado é o satanás como
fruta ou como tomado como uma sanfona
piccino tomada
o satanás costa ps agora é agora docente
do ó santana pregou o canto real agora
vai por cima que o anderson e cria um
canhão tudo fudid manual frente dó alô
taí alguém está aceso isso quer dizer
que alguém dentro eu vou abrir a porta a
porta abriu e errado com uma assim que a
porta do flash é porta do quartel o dem
já vamos ter daqui pronto e é tudo
dentro de portas fechadas gd direito
outra sala com luz seja meu deus é que
faltava o satanás não fica impressionada
tava afim de olha é que tá jesus só com
cuidado jesus ao contrário os mesmos
curva mesmo que está fora de si mesmo
embora bora bora bora pra escolher
memória lá era tudo escuro não pensei
[ __ ] nenhuma de que o córtex uma porta
encontrar a porta será que é aqui que
está o satanás não não é que não
funciona no rap meu deus nem sequer pode
preparar o equipamento como assim aqui
há mais qualquer coisa têm aqui uma
passagem à outra porta ganhava porto a
registar um busto é um busto de uma
pessoa ter que fugir olha só a boca foi
apanhado pelo jack o estripador lado dá
uma passada pontual isto é coisa sabem
quem é coisa do santa na china que
apanhar o satanás bora lá por outra
porta aqui ó
entrámos num quarto novo será que está
aqui os a nasa está aqui a gasolina com
a sonhar isso não posso e eles formaram
com certeza com certeza que vai abrir
este armários em não apertar a abril uma
pistola não gostava de entrar no bbb 3
não a bateria eu faço ae
então agora eu preciso ir apanhar pilhas
para o chile porque não leva teria 90
lixo vamos à procura de ajuda
apenas pepe eu supostamente apanhei uma
bateria lá atrás é aquela coisa
horrorosa nexis outra bateria então é
preciso duas vamos lá então em busca da
bateria é eu já não sei onde actua já
perdeu outra vez é muito escura ea
faltou entrar nisto a cryptic meu deus ó
uma mensagem para fundiu o satanás parte
uma luxo não quer pagar o gaúcho era o
que dizia que 15 m e óssea am e orsoni
15m e ordens sabe que eu tenho um filho
eu tenho que entregar o meu filho pro
sant''anna acha eu tenho um filho onde é
que eu fiz um filho e eu não tenho filho
nenhum só chegamos no tre parte da
prisão eu acho e as portas da fábrica
não tá tudo chato com o campeão ou só
colocou no chão como assim ue free que
tá frio está frio eu vou querer o quê a
1 com a um cadáver será um cadáver não
vamos fazer saltar vivo senhor está
claramente morto claramente ó tem outra
filha já encontra já encontrar já posso
entender já tem flash lite o eu já posso
trabalhar em equipe ea qualquer coisa
não abandonava a a que já opera perto
aqui é que já há agora a cena começou a
sentir a que está aqui coisas do paraná
uma aula e deve investigar nada está
tudo vazio como assim o caso vamos lá
por cima lá pra cima eu sei que tem uma
zona escura portanto é por lá que nós
vai me espera
eu entrei aqui a não está para aí estava
tapado assim luciano ducci aqui e isso
cai pessoal vamos investigar agora as
células tudo direitinho vamos investigar
isso tudo eu sei que vai perceber que um
susto mas foram se não gostar poço cujo
uso mesmo vamos embora vamos então lá
pro senhor acha que é por aqui mesmo que
já está a ficar perigoso jato sentir o
matrimônio jááá encontrou o canto de um
portão tudo escuro o ombro eo pessoal
agora é agora sustos steel favor assim
tom poderes nem sequer vai ter suas
rochas têm um aparelho de textura esta
na parede e os fizeram esta preto com os
feira 21 10 em seguida eu fui apanhar
uma bíblia para chegar a um beco sem
seguir a série é nosso lar para chuva a
cair vamos voltar para trás
não é por aqui a tem uma escada aqui por
cima agora compreendo o muitas casas
agora nada acontece
a série que insistiu que nem vai ter um
susto nem um sustinho meu deus mas um só
país não só a categoria primária uma
porta e forjadas por já parece uma porta
de ferro laminado com 12 pontos de 4 na
escala de ritcher curso técnico de
portas de domínio obviamente que só a
caiana lá abre a porta o que é aquela
maçaneta rodou com um ano dos 172
gravosas que está avariado temos que
trocar 21 só com a minha como a minha
flash lite ilumina o iraque tem luz a ok
já não tem já desapareceu
agora 116 boka que eu tenho eo
terminator o exterminador implacável não
ia pound seu eu não percebo esta letra
onu e about to be with you foi um
sacrifício do santuário acho eu sou
botafogo de matar um estão médico e eu
nem sei um cientista e eu já não sei
onde executou olha que este olha só isso
a porta bem futurista é que nós temos
que ir para ela é preciso cole que eu
sou um gênio e os vinhos jogos então o
código vai ser para mim as portas de
alumínio foram inventadas em 1827
portanto há de ser pêra não há um número
um é sério e se isso vai desde 2009 como
foi o confronto foi em 2000 930 e não
foi